how's it going brother my name
is welcome to kwop I am I have traveled
zero Z zero I can't talk I'm sorry
anyway hey don't fall man don't do it
don't do it no hey don't eat your hand
man God damn it showing real car okay
the point of this game is pretty much to
run but it's just hard as the hardest
what kiss it kiss the go line or what
the hell is wrong with his leg what the
hell man okay come on I can do it I can
do
it it is I don't look at me and be like
oh it's easy no it's not easy it's
difficult okay I got a good tactic here
ow that got to hurt man
what hey I got one and a half meter 1.1
actually hey that's not forward that's
bad what why do you always kissing man
what kiss it ah [__] [__] that's not a
kiss forward forward do you [__] know
forward is there any like oh I'm
pressing the wrong buttons that's maybe
oh nice split
dude
whoa oh okay I got it
oh okay maybe don't get
it huh yeah
oh uh-huh no
there we go yeah okay okay okay yeah
yeah no no no no no no
no yeah yeah feel
fabulous look at this oh yeah yeah look
at this I'm
dancing yeah yeah
oh yeah look at this okay how did I do
that whoa I'm
fabulous uh uh I'm not fabulous
anymore okay come on I got to make it 10
meters or some whoa gorgeous man how did
I do the first one how how did
I I did a [__] thing where
I I don't H maybe we maybe we need like
some inspirational music or some [__] I
think I
[Music]
fake going
the hat is going to hate I laugh C your
face yeah problem
barrels [__] 1.3 M are you there we
go
1.7 okay how was it I walk right leg
yes yeah yeah that's
happening oh yeah I think we got a new
tactic coming that is not the tactic I
wanted
what holy [__] no not back
no no
why ah [__] me come
on ah come on man
you [__] stink as walk it's not that
oh oh what is he doing yes new
record [__] yeah all right here we
go no that's back [__]
oh 2.7 [__] come
on
yes okay I can do this I can win this
[__] now oh no all right this time for
my mom for my dad for my I don't pet
named R rulas why would I name my pet
rulas it's so bad at naming pets just as
I am is running why what's my purpose in
life I can't even why I I even get this
suit on if I can't even [__] walk how
do I get to this point in my life this
is terrible what am I it's working I
don't know what I'm doing mying shut
over there [__]
you know what [__] it anyway that was
kwop I know a lot of you br Su just that
I played post a video response if you
beat my amazing 2.7 I'd like to see I'll
leave a link in the description if you
want to try it and that's pretty much it
like you enjoy subscribe to come and
I'll see you next episode of whatever I
probably not this game though anyway
stay awesome bro Santa T
it hey watch out for that who nice Dodge
Santa I'm humping
[__] yeah Santa we're doing this [__]
you Santa I'm doing it alone with
pineapple [__] yeah best winning post
ever